in the immediate aftermath of this
horrible terrorist shooting incident in
buffalo new york over the weekend we
talked about it monday we talked about
it tuesday this was an individual a
white 18 year old domestically born
american who was specifically targeting
black people influenced by right-wing
ideas regularly parroted out on fox news
including of the white replacement
theory or great replacement theory white
birth rates and other things in the
immediate aftermath of that i already
told you that uh there was a segment on
fox news where they did their normal dog
and pony show where they talk about
violence in video games as possibly a
cause for this shooting we've also seen
the promulgators of the exact same
ideology that the shooter cites in his
manifesto
people like tucker carlson and others
say this was just a lone incident of
mental illness that's all it was there's
no politics here there's no ideology
there's no conservatism or liberalism
and we also saw ben shapiro say if there
is politics here it really sounds more
like wokeness than anything else which
is of course completely untrue the ideas
in the manifesto
are being espoused exclusively by
right-wing political commentators well
let me now show you some other attempts
to shift and place blame in absurd and
pathetic ways happening on fox news
jesse waters pulls out it's sort of like
i don't it's kind of like uh pulling
random reasons out of a hat a maga hat i
guess we could say
lockdowns
forced masking and woke ideology
are what jesse waters says really we
should be looking at as the causes of
the buffalo shooting take a look at this
this is from yesterday we have a crisis
right now the american public education
system is hurting our kids
math and reading rates are plummeting
studies are showing that kids are
talking less
they're already warning about a third of
elementary school students need quote
intensive support but our leaders don't
care they're more concerned about how
they're going to force masks back on
kids
some school districts in california and
new jersey
have just implemented fresh mask
mandates in classrooms this week
we're setting these kids up for failure
for a generation deep in a mental health
crisis after lockdowns forced masking
woke ideology kids are feeling depressed
just look at what happened in the
buffalo situation what a teenager whose
school system failed him decided his
only option was to turn to the dark web
where he was radicalized
a failed education system let that
happen but the so-called experts think
they haven't done anything wrong watch
so
has jesse waters seen the tucker carlson
show
because if so he'd know exactly what
inspired the shooter the shooter's
manifesto verbatim has talking points
from tucker carlson's show in it
masking what
and jesse waters brings up
fair and concerning things it is true
that covet-era babies many of them now
toddlers
seem to have something going on in terms
of language development i've read that
that's concerning we've got to deal with
that
the shooter's 18.
okay the shooter was 16 when kovitz
started and the idea that that's what
left the shooter no choice but to go out
and target black people even if it were
the case that you had
limited language development due to
masking doesn't make you go and target
black people it's a completely absurd
claim and they don't know what to do
they don't know what to say
because their ideology is verbatim in
the manifesto now by the way
constant mass shootings also aren't
happening in any other advanced country
where they had masking
and by sort of like nor you know what we
call normal schooling where you learn
empiricism and science and stuff like
that
they call it woke schooling they have it
in other countries as well and they
don't have the mass shooting problem one
thing they don't have is ready access to
so many guns the party of personal
responsibility as you can see
blaming the left for making this guy
murder innocent people this guy is a
complete and total joke now here's
another example this one's also from fox
news this is
kennedy lisa kennedy
she links
abortion
and the sort of disregard for human life
that she says is implicit in abortion
to shooting she says when we disregard
human life
of course you get shootings wild stuff
just not and i know a lot of people a
lot of democrats who say i am pro-choice
but i don't believe that we should be
killing babies after 15 weeks i
certainly don't think that we should be
performing these procedures and
celebrating them at 20 weeks you have a
lot of democrats saying you know we used
to hear safe legal and rare you don't
hear that anymore you hear people
chanting about how great abortion is
regardless of how you feel about whether
or not the courts or congress should be
involved that is not something to be
celebrated and we have lost the plot as
a society so don't be surprised when
there are mass casualty events at the
hands of sociopaths we have so little
regard for human life and that starts
with basic decent conversations where we
have mutual dignity and curiosity we
have to find a way to get back to that
place even when we disagree vehemently
so you think that people who seek
abortions are sociopaths no i'm saying
that mass shooters are sociopaths mass
shooters and people like that are raised
to have very little respect for human
life and i think we have to get back to
a place in society where we do have
respect for each other where you don't
have people going on the subway and
shooting people and trying to okay so
it's it's a very very dumb show but her
argument is
mass shooters don't have respect for
life and for society and people who
gleefully get abortions as she claims
people do don't have respect for life in
society and so the link is
in general when you don't have respect
for life and society you either go and
get abortions or you go and do a mass
shooting it's hard to imagine a dumber
take it truly is
but they are desperate to blame anything
they can
other than looking inward and i get it
it's hard to look inward when when the
blame is on you and again we're not
saying legal blame but when we what we
are saying is
the ideology espoused by the shooter's
manifesto
is an ideology that has been nurtured
and incubated in right-wing media and
fox news is part of it whether kennedy's
herself talked about white replacement
theory or not i don't know maybe she
didn't but at this point there's no way
that she could not realize that many of
the people on her network are the ones
pushing the same stuff that was in the
manifesto you look everywhere else
abortion's the reason
uh or masking or woke education or
whatever the case may be they're not
going to look inward uh but we have to
remember that we know exactly why the
shooter did what they did
one of our longtime sponsors is vincero
collective if you don't know vincero yet
it's the place to go for quality watches
sunglasses and more
serious style
undeniable quality and total versatility
put vincero really at the top of the
game and their newest watch release
is no exception it's the argo automatic
it spotlights everything i love about
vincero i got the argo automatic in
frost white this is a dive watch which
is of course a staple in the watch world
but i really think vincero found a way
to make this one stand out i love the
gradient blue accent of the hour markers
against the solid white face i really
love all of their watches and i own a
bunch but the argo is probably my
favorite so far
vincero sunglasses and jewelry and other
accessories are awesome too
an excellent way to elevate any outfit
vincero collective is giving my audience
fifteen percent off all products and
free shipping go to
vincerocollective.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below